nasa astronaut scott kelly spent almost
one year orbiting Earth aboard the
International Space Station while his
identical twin brother Mark Kelly who is
also an astronaut spent that same time
here on earth this gave NASA the unique
opportunity to study the impact of
long-term space travel on human biology
to find out more we talked to one of the
study's lead authors dr. Francine
Garrett Bakeman you know it's rare to
have twins and it's even rarer to have
twins that are both astronauts right I
mean that's unheard of NASA and really
Scott Kelly came up with this concept
that it would be really great to do this
research project and study the effects
of long-term spaceflight on not only
physiological parameters that NASA
really studies heavily and has been for
many many decades but to really expand
that to include molecular information
and some additional parameters that
might be important for long-term space
travel using his brother as a control as
a reference because they're genetically
identical scott kelly collected
biological samples like blood and urine
while he was in space and at the same
time his brother Mark Kelly was on earth
collecting the exact same kinds of
samples so describe to me one of the
more high-stakes scenarios that you were
involved in personally receiving a
high-priority sample having the process
of you know right then are you up first
like are you up in like two o'clock in
the morning what's going on if you
recall he landed around midnight - there
were actually two specimens coming in
one was collected on the space station
right before he left and came down with
him the second one was planned to be
collected from him when he got to the
Johnson Space Center you know I got
these two specimens or like two o'clock
in the morning 2:30 in the morning and I
was in the lab till around 8 9 o'clock
in the morning working continuously you
know and that was that was a big
responsibility because if I would have
made a mistake that night
the results would have been different
but that was really I would say for me
that was kind of a highlight experience
because in science you don't routinely
get to experience something like that
right if you're working with something
in the laboratory usually you can get
more material not always but usually um
and it's not like you get one or two
tubes and and it's your it's your one
shot right you can't reproduce this no
you can't like how like one is the next
time you're gonna have when is the next
entry to get twins that's just not gonna
work right so that was kind of unique I
have to say let's talk about the biggest
takeaways from what you found because
you were looking at a lot of stuff right
you're looking at you're looking at
epigenetics you're looking at genetic
expression you're also looking at
microbiome stuff you're looking at
cognitive functions so you covered a lot
of territory let's talk about what the
biggest takeaways were preliminary
there's a strong suggestion that human
biology can be maintained at the
cellular level not just physiological
level and that that will really
facilitate long-term travel and safety
for astronauts long-term um I would say
the next most important findings aboard
the telomere caps the telomeres the caps
of the chromosomes got longer in
spaceflight that was unexpected the
telomeres are really these these caps
that sit on the edges of chromosomes and
and they protect our genetic material
from becoming damaged and every test we
did basically showed the same result
that the telomeres got longer with
flight and within two days of him coming
back they shrunk down to where they were
the next finding which I was involved
with was the gene expression data there
was a lot of gene changes and
inflammation and stress responses be and
to be expected to see I would have been
shocked if there were it gene expression
refers to whether a section of your DNA
is turned on or off some genes control
for fixed traits like eye color
others like the ones that help regulate
your metabolism or turning off and on
all the time I mean the thing people
need to remember right is like gene
expression changes in response to
everything yeah every day every hour
right every day every hour and so it
would have been shocking if we saw
nothing
he had gene expression changes that were
correlated with the time that he was in
space and after he came back the vast
majority of those greater than 90
percent came back to where they were
before flight by the six-month mark
after he'd returned who knows if we
would have measured that a year late
like a year after return maybe that
number would be much higher 95 96 97 two
years later maybe everything's back to
normal we just don't know the answer to
that we already know that space travel
is rough on humans for instance it can
interfere with the movement of fluids in
the body because there's no gravity they
can accumulate in the head and this can
have a number of side effects up to 40%
of astronauts have lasting vision
problems but this study is the beginning
of understanding more about what happens
to the human body in space it points the
way towards questions that you know NASA
or other space agencies might ask about
what kind of protective measures can we
take when we're sending people to space
we already know that in microgravity you
lose muscle mass you lose bone density
and they've developed sort of exercise
regimens to counteract that right but
like maybe there's a pillow we could
take in the future that could help with
some of these absolutely absolutely time
will tell what if any are the
implications of these findings for
longer duration space missions people
talk about a mission to Mars right and a
flyby mission to Mars not even touching
down going around coming home that's 500
days I think it gives us some
perspective and direction of the areas
in molecular biology that should be
focused on and should be studied further
but the first step to this will be to
basically reproduce the study in
additional astronauts who will be on the
International Space Station for a year
and then
as the space agencies start traveling
further out the same studies will have
to be repeated to see if these things
are reproducible because it could be
that this is an N of 1 and its an N of 1
and we will never see this again right
it could be that it could be that
Scottish is particularly resistant to
the ravages of space right yeah one one
thing to keep in mind though is that
when the astronauts on the International
Space Station they have a very strict
diet and a very strict exercise regimen
and so it could be that what we detected
was actually a consequence of this
lifestyle change they might be living
healthier lives in space than Mars on
earth and he is a Caucasian male if it's
a african-american male woman who knows
if these will be reproducible and so we
have to be careful with what we think in
what we say because it's really hard to
tell what the implications are but I
think at the end of the day the study
was informative it gives insight into
the potential molecular mechanisms that
might be affected by state by
spaceflight and they can give direction
for countermeasures to be considered and
additional studies to be done in the
future hey thank you again so much for
joining us thanks for the opportunity to
chat today